so the Oscar nominations were announced
today and I actually was not up for the
initial announcement but I have stayed
away for my Twitter feed and my Facebook
and email and all that stuff so that I
can create a genuine live reaction video
to the Oscar nominations being announced
like I have done for the past three
years in a row I have received many
requests to do this in the past few days
and I definitely want to do that for you
guys some of my biggest hopes are Jake
Gyllenhaal for Nightcrawler he needs it
he absolutely requires that nomination
his work was incredible I would love to
see some love for whiplash because I
think bird mail get nominated for like a
ton of stuff but whiplash is like a
movie that was my number two of the year
and I feel like it might not get
nominations that it deserves I'm sure
you'll get JK Simmons but I think it
should get a lot more than that so I'm
hoping of course I'm positive Meryl
Streep will get nominated for into the
woods it would be really cool if the
Academy actually honored the tale to
Princess Kaguya with the Best Animated
nomination I seriously doubt they will
but if they did that would be awesome
more than likely there'll be a ton of
snubs as usual but I'm not gonna be too
surprised because the Academy just
doesn't surprise me anymore however if
they don't nominate John Hall I will
actually be upset I'm not gonna show my
reactions to every category just the
major ones for Best Original Song the
nominees are everything is awesome from
the lego movie
good good good glory from sulla good
grateful from jana lights I'm not gonna
miss you from Gwen Campbell I'll be me
and lost stars from begin again for
achievement in visual effects the
nominees are Captain America the Winter
Soldier and visual effects on of the
planet will be a great visual effects
guardian of the galaxy Guardian realitor
stellar interstellar of course x-men
Days of Future x-men best animated
feature film the nominees are big hero 6
nice the boxtrolls ok How to Train Your
Dragon 2 good song of the sea'
and Samia and the tale of the princess
kaguya whoa good issues good stay tuned
for the second part of our announcement
no lego movie though that's interesting
but that being said I'm really surprised
they nominated the taylor princess
kaguya that makes me happy um but no
lego movie hmm and I saw boxtrolls i
didn't review the movie i didn't really
think it was that great I'll probably
give it like a C+ I do not think it's
better than a lego movie
not even remotely so that's kind of
stupid but you know whatever they
nominated the song so it's all good poor
performance by an actor in a supporting
role JK Simmons give me Simmons Robert
Duvall in the judge Ethan Hawke and boy
we're good Edward Norton in Birdman or
the unexpected virtue Oh God come
through the whole title Mark Ruffalo in
Foxcatcher good and JK thank goodness
thank goodness performance by an actress
in a supporting role the nominees are
I guarantee Meryl Streep Patricia
Arquette in boyhood excellent Laura Dern
and wild hello
Keira Knightley in the imitation game of
course Emma Stone in Birdman or the
unexpected virtue she was good I guess
and Meryl Streep in into the woods of
course she's a good actress she's a good
actress okay she's a really good actress
but did never mind parchment in
cinematographer Jimmy burn man Jimmy
Birdman Emmanuel Lubezki for Birdman or
the unexpected virtue of ignorance good
good good Robert yeoman for the grand
Budapest hotel excellent
Luke OSH y'all and recharge Lin Shu ski
for Edith dick poop dick poop for mr.
Turner
and Roger Deakins for on bro okay Roger
Deakins yeah good good good but holy
ah she said dick poop she actually
said dick poop I'm 12 years old
apparently good job dick poop
you got nominee
Wofford apid screenplay the nominees are
Jason hall for American sniper Graham
Moore for the imitation game good Paul
Thomas Anderson for inherent vice
Anthony McCartan for the theory of
everything
Damien Chazelle for whiplash nice that's
good for original screenplay nominees Oh
give me Nightcrawler please Alejandro G
Inarritu
and Nicolas jakab own Alexander I love
this woman to be pronouncing his name no
bow for the Birdman or the unexpected
virtue of ignorance can just say Birdman
Richard Linklater nice good Emacs FRA
and Dan Futterman are Foxcatcher Wes
Anderson and Hugo Guinness Budapest
hotel
give me Nightcrawler and Dan Gilroy okay
that's that's a little bets none that's
a little something for me thank you for
it'll score the nominees are
give me Hans Zimmer Alexandre Desplat
for the grand Budapest hotel great score
Alexandre Desplat for the imitation
great score Hans Zimmer for interstellar
amazing square you're shooting for mr
Turner
haven't seen it yo Han Yeo handsome for
the theory of everything cool thank you
for Hans Zimmer for achievement in
directing the nominees are Alejandro G
in yachty two men or the unexpected
virtue of ignorance richard linklater
for boyhood very good Bennett Miller for
Foxcatcher good directing Wes Anderson
for the grand Budapest hotel excellent
direct and Morton Tilden for the
imitation game okay best director Damien
Chazelle maybe for whiplash now look
I've already forgotten about the fact
that the babadook won't get nominated
because for whatever reason it's not
eligible because you know it's just a
movie that came out last year you know
around the world so why would it be
eligible yeah SC Davis gave the best
performance by an actress of the year in
my opinion she won't get nominated
nothing in the film will even notes my
third film favorite of the year
whatever I've forgotten all about that
that being said
not a single woman nominated I just
noticed in the directing category not
the director of Selma not Angela and
Jolie for unbroken which I have not seen
yet so I can't really say but honestly
if I were running these Oscars I would
have nominated Jennifer Kent for the
babadook her direction was so good and
just just just whatever poor performance
by an actress in a leading room give me
Rosamund Pike nominees are Marion
Cotillard
in two days one night I'm sure comedy
Jones
I'm sure ton of people saw that movie
Julianne Moore in still out I saw that
I'll review that soon Rosamund Pike
thank you girl
apparently it's Rosamund and reese
witherspoon in Wilde of course she was
good in the movie but Robin Pike better
win unlike at the Golden Globes by the
way which was stupid Rosman Pike gave a
considerably better performance than
Julianne Moore did I did see still Alice
she was good in the movie that being
said I just don't think Rosman Pike's in
the club yet or whatever Julianne Moore
gets nominated for everything it's it's
stupid Rosman Pike gave a truly
breakthrough performance for a female
this year and yeah so careful Oscars
careful for performance by an actor in a
leading role the nominee give me Jake
Gyllenhaal you mother Carell and
Foxcatcher he was good Bradley Cooper an
American sniper
he was good too Benedict Cumberbatch in
the imitation game he was good give me
David elo Keaton and Bergman awesome the
unexpected virtue of a video or or in
any Redmayne in the theory of everything
them them them them
I am done with the Oscars I'm
officially done with the Oscars
okay here's the deal before you get
ready to comment Chris calm down it's
just an award show you're allowed to
have your opinion doesn't really matter
it's a whole bunch of political BS I
know it doesn't mean that I don't like
to see people be honored for stuff that
they do that's good you know Jake
Gyllenhaal is considered is constantly
just not in the club or whatever for
these Oscar people it's just anyway what
else happened and finally we are pleased
to announce the
selected as the Best Picture nominees I
don't give a sh a are American sniper
really really I saw it
our view but seriously Best Picture
Bergman great unexpected good movie row
G in yari to John ledger and James W
Scott Chapel producers I'm I'm crushed
boy hood Richard Linklater and cat
excellent movie producers not surprising
the grand Budapest hotel also very good
Scott Rudin Steven rail hurry up
producers uh the imitation game door
across very good movie II do Ostrovsky
and Teddy Schwartzman producers
you guys are like Christmas Thelma Oh
finally some love for Selma DD Gardner
and Jeremy kleiner producers the theory
of everything
yeah I'm sure yeah Lisa Bruce and
Anthony McCartney
producers come on give me something in
witless Oh
Jason Blum Helen Esterbrook and David
Lancaster producers finally something to
be excited about
she quiet Captain Kirk you're attractive
but be quiet
alright so that's cool whiplash got
nominated for Best Picture I truly did
not expect that that's awesome I'm also
really happy about Princess Kaguya being
nominated for animated picture but no
Jake Gyllenhaal
no David Oh yellow whoa uh no female
directing uh I think did I did I count
right there were eight best pictures
announced they have opportunities to
nominate ten but they chose to nominate
eight because they want people to yell
and be upset I guess look I've seen
American sniper I'll review that this
weekend I do think it is a good movie
but I don't think it's a best picture of
the year that's for sure
for goodness sakes there are so many
other better films out there I don't
understand the Academy has their little
Club they love honoring the little club
and that's all they do every year and
it's
pissing me off no jake gyllenhaal
seriously the man was a different person
nothing for Nightcrawler except I think
it was Best Screenplay which was very
good but for goodness sakes
Steve Carell was excellent in Foxcatcher
but a lot of his performance was done
entirely by makeup take that makeup away
and it wouldn't have been nearly as
enthralling Jake Gyllenhaal transformed
himself completely and he deserves an
Oscar nomination ah those are my
thoughts on the Oscars if you haven't
been able to tell I'm not really a huge
fan of the ceremony I am not really a
big fan of it at all I've kind of lost
hope in the past few years that they
will ever actually bring forth things in
the art and entertainment industry
that's actually truly worthy of praise
like yes they nominate things that are
worth that's for sure I mean like they
nominate good stuff but at this point to
me it's just a popularity contest and
I'm tired of it it's almost like the
People's Choice Awards except the
People's Choice are the Academy they
just nominate their buddies and it's
it's kind of sickening actually so those
are my thoughts on the Academy Award
nominations what are your thoughts in
the Academy Award nominations let me
know below and as always thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
man eyes
Oh